So here's a more challenging quiz about find. This one will require you
to think pretty carefully about how find is defined. For any string, so
we're going to have a variable s that we've initialized to any string. Your
goal is to determine which of these will always have the value zero.
So the first choice, s.find (s). Notice there are no quotes around s. The
second one is s.find('s'). The third one is
's'.find('s'). The fourth one is
s.find(''). And the final
one is s.find Passing
in s concatenated with the string. Three exclamation points, one of my favorites
plus one. So check all of the answers where the expression here
evaluates to zero, no matter what value the string s starts with. So try
to answer this, just based on thinking, understanding the description of find.
You can always also try things in the Python interpreter
after that. And see if your interpretation is correct. But remember
our goal is to answer the question where no matter
what the string S is, the resultive expression is always zero.